В ефірі новини «heute» з Мітрієм Зіріним.
Добрий вечір. Сподіваємося,
спека не надто виснажила вас.
Сьогодні працюємо у тандемі з Крістін Отто,
яка традиційно розповість новини спорту.
Нерозлучні, як завжди. Вітаю вас.
Сьогодні у випуску:
суперечки щодо газової турбіни.
Канцлер Шольц запевнив, що турбіна цілком готова
до транспортування до РФ.
Москва скаржиться на відсутність необхідних документів.
Загрозливі сигнали після візиту Пелосі.
Китай демонструє свою військову міць
у відповідь на візит
спікерки Палати представників США до Тайваню.
Температури в Німеччині зростають.
Проте спека ще не досягла свого апогею.
У деяких регіонах розпочалася справжня засуха.
З червня Росія суттєво урізала
постачання газу до Німеччини,
обґрунтувавши це рішення
несправністю газової турбіни.
Німецький уряд вважає причину надуманою.
Сьогодні канцлер
заявив про це особливо відверто.
На зустрічі в Мюльгаймі-на-Рурі Шольц оглянув
цілком готову до введення в експлуатацію турбіну
та чітко дав зрозуміти, що йдеться зовсім не про
технічну несправність.
Карл Гінтерляйтнер далі.
Турбіна важить майже 20 тонн
і лише вона може покласти край
газовій кризі в Німеччині.
Тижнями місце її перебування тримали в секреті
з міркувань безпеки.
Сьогодні ж канцлер Шольц завітав до Мюльгайму-на-Рурі,
щоб особисто перевірити справність турбіни.
Його висновок - турбіна цілком готова для використання.
Для мене важливо сказати чітко тут і зараз,
що турбіна готова до введення
в експлуатацію будь-якої миті.
Тому я не бачу перешкод для
транспортування турбіни до Росії.
«Gazprom» створював міф, що нібито все газопостачання
залежить саме від цієї турбіни
і без неї можливе постачання лише 20% газу.
Проте зараз, коли турбіна абсолютно готова,
у РФ заявили про відсутність
необхідної митної інформації для транспортування.
У Німеччині таке пояснення не вважають валідним.
Ми запевняємо, що з нашого боку всі митні папери,
необхідні для транспортування, готові.
Інформація про технічну несправність не має
фактичного обґрунтування.
Саме так виглядає ситуація насправді.
Ексканцлер та друг Путіна Герхард Шредер
теж висловив свою позицію.
В інтерв'ю виданню «Stern» він підтримав ідею
введення до експлуатації «Північного потоку-2».
Все одно він вже готовий. За справді скрутних умов
ми можемо розраховувати на цей газопровід.
Якби обидва «Північних потоки» було введено в експлуатацію,
Німеччині вдалося б уникнути газової кризи.
Однак проблемам із постачанням вдалося б запобігти,
якби газопровід «Північний потік-1» працював на повну
потужність, як це передбачала двостороння угода.
Втім, цей сценарій є малоймовірним, Росія навряд чи
відкриє свій газовий кран на повну найближчим часом.
Обговоримо питання з експертами. З нами на зв'язку
Фібі Гаа з Москви та Матіс Фельдгоф з Берліна.
Матісе, як сьогоднішній візит Олафа Шольца
вплине на ситуацію?
Сьогодні канцлер Шольц чітко дав зрозуміти:
Росія бреше.
Турбіна на місці і вона цілком готова для використання.
У своїй промові Шольц недвозначно повідомив,
що саме Росія винна в затримці транспортування
і вона не зупиниться ні перед чим та буде використовувати
газ як засіб тиску на Європу, як справжню зброю.
Усі, хто стверджують протилежне,
як-от прессекретар президента РФ Пєсков
чи ексканцлер Герхард Шредер, приховують правду.
Заява Шольца - це непросто сигнал Путіну,
а й заклик до німецького народу
не піддаватися кремлівській пропаганді.
Шольц прагне протистояти цій пропаганді,
однією з головних оман якої є, скажімо, те, що
причиною газової кризи стали санкції проти Росії.
Один із урядовців влучно сказав, що Шольц надзвичайно
вдало підібрав день для свого сенсаційного візиту,
натякаючи на сумнозвісне інтерв'ю друга Путіна
Герхарда Шредера.
На зв'язку Фібі Гаа з Москви.
У Німеччині стверджують, що турбіна абсолютно готова
і саме Москва гальмує процес транспортування.
У чому ж проблема насправді?
У Москві запевняють, що проблема якраз у Німеччині.
Риторика «Gazprom» стосовно турбіни
німецької компанії «Siemens»не змінилася -
у Москві продовжують стверджувати про відсутність
необхідних для транспортування документів.
Загалом історія з турбіною чудово вписалася в класичний
наратив російської пропаганди -
нібито санкції Заходу більше нашкодять
самому Заходу, аніж Росії.
Тут я хочу виділити три основні пункти:
по-перше, турбіна потрапила під санкції Канади, а не ЄС.
Для Росії це сигнал про відсутність єдності на Заході.
По-друге, Німеччина попросила Канаду
зробити виняток із санкцій.
Для Кремля ж це черговий доказ залежності
Німеччини від російського газу.
І по-третє, Канада погодилася зробити виняток
для турбіни компанії «Siemens»,
і це лише пробудило сподівання Росії на те, що,
можливо, санкції послабляться і в інших галузях,
якщо Європу добряче притиснути.
Дякую за ваші експертні оцінки, колеги.
З нами на зв'язку була
Фібі Гаа з Москви та Матіс Фельдгоф із Берліна.
Не потрібно бути провидцем, щоб зрозуміти,
що наступна осінь та зима для багатьох
видадуться тяжкими.
Постійне зростання цін, зокрема, на енергоносії,
стане важким тягарем для громадян.
Незважаючи на те, що
канцлер сьогодні вкотре підкреслив,
що держава не залишить людей у скруті,
вже з'явилися перші тривожні дзвіночки, які
змусили громадян засумніватися в словах Олафа Шольца.
Ніна Нібергалль розповість більше.
Від нових платіжок за газ у людей навертаються сльози.
Незабаром Айлін та Штефані Ермлінг з Кельна
доведеться платити удвічі більше.
Вони занепокоєні, що грошей може не вистачити.
Останніми місяцями стрімко зросли
ціни на продукти та пальне.
А тепер здорожчав і газ.
Ми вчора поглянули одна на одну і зрозуміли, що нас
бентежить спільне питання - як же перезимувати?
З жовтня кельнський енергопостачальник «RheinEnergie»
суттєво підвищить тарифи на газ.
Громадяни, які живуть у квартирах середніх розмірів,
платитимуть 2002 євро щорічно.
Раніше плата становила близько 960 євро,
отже, ціна зросла на 108%.
Інші газопостачальники вже давно підвищили тарифи,
різниця подекуди ще більша.
Згідно з сайтом «Vergleichsportal»,
в середньому протягом року ціна на газ зросла на 184%.
При цьому ресурс не враховував осінні тарифи.
Уряд справді робив певні спроби полегшити
фінансовий тягар, який ліг на плечі населенню,
однак всі вони вичерпалися наприкінці серпня.
Восени уряд має на меті запустити масштабну програму
субсидування споживачів, однак паралельно з нею
спостерігатиметься значне підвищення тарифів.
Це не зовсім справедливо.
Федеральний уряд повинен
запропонувати новий пакет допомоги
безпосередньо тим громадянам, які
потребують цього.
Саме такий намір має канцлер Шольц.
Му будемо вживати подальших заходів
передусім, щоб допомогти людям,
яких спіткала скрута.
Зважаючи на складну ситуацію у світі, ми розуміємо,
що не всі громадяни мають необхідні заощадження.
Тому ми вирішили суттєво підвищити допомогу на житло.
Також ми плануємо провести низку реформ
у галузі базового державного забезпечення,
починаючи з 1 січня 2023 року.
Айлін і Штефані Ермлінг налаштовані скептично.
Вони вважають, що грошей ледве вистачатиме на
те, щоб просто вижити.
Невдовзі в них з'явиться дитина.
Тому вони планували переїхати
в трикімнатну квартиру.
Проте зараз подружжя не може собі цього дозволити.
Після візиту спікерки Палати представників США
Ненсі Пелосі до Тайваню
Китай вирішив пограти військовими м'язами.
Близько трьох годин 27 китайських військових літаків
демонстративно перетинали зону протиповітряної оборони Тайваню.
Китай погрожує подальшими
військовими заходами
та відверто претендує на самовладний острів Тайвань.
Про, можливо, наступну масштабну безпекову кризу
у світі розповість Ульф Реллер.
Китай усіляко намагався завадити цій зустрічі.
Спікерку Палати представників США Ненсі Пелосі
зустрічає президентка Тайваню Цай Інвень.
Зустріч стала чітким сигналом для Китаю:
США допомагатимуть Тайваню
відстоювати свою незалежність.
Пелосі добре усвідомлює свою впливовість
та чудово розуміє, що реакція офіційного Пекіна
на візит не змусить довго на себе чекати.
Ми відчуваємо відповідальність за
гарантії безпеки Тайваню
та хочемо, щоб країна змогла за себе постояти.
Йдеться про демократію та свободу,
які зразково демонструє Тайвань.
Коли Пелосі промовляла ці слова,
керівництво Китаю віддавало наказ про бойову
готовність свого війська.
Влада оголосила про початок військових навчань
з метою утримання Тайваню.
Офіційний Пекін вважає Тайвань островом-відступником,
який історично належать материковому Китаю.
Війська розпочинають свої навчання,
не шкодуючи важкого озброєння.
Пекін понад усе прагне возз'єднання з Тайванем,
навіть якщо досягнути його вдасться
лише військовим шляхом.
Тайвань ніколи не був незалежною країною.
Тайвань - це історична провінція
Китайської Народної Республіки.
Візит Пелосі неабияк сколихнув
Індо-Тихоокеанський регіон.
Китайська армія вже завтра
почне оточувати Тайвань.
Президент КНР Сі Цзіньпін
прагне продемонструвати
свою міць та лідерство,
щоб не виглядати слабким на тлі могутніх суперників.
Ненсі Пелосі вилетіла з Тайваню,
однак наслідки її візиту будуть відчутними ще довго.
Китай почав демонстративно стягувати танки до
кордону, близько за 160 кілометрів від узбережжя Тайваню.
Поки що Китай лише інсценує воєнні дії.
А зараз про війну в Україні та її наслідки.
Вантажне судно з українською кукурудзою, що
нещодавно вийшло з Одеського порту,
подолало чергову перешкоду на своєму нелегкому шляху.
Судно успішно пройшло інспекцію та продовжило
свій шлях у напрямку Лівану.
Представники Росії, Туреччини, України та ООН
перевіряли судно та товаросупровідні документи
протягом трьох годин у порту Стамбула.
Жодних порушень не було виявлено.
«Razoni» став першим кораблем,
якому вдалося покинути Україну від початку війни.
Міжнародне агентство з атомної енергії
занепокоєне ситуацією на Запорізькій атомній електростанції,
розташованій в окупованій частині України.
Гендиректор МАГАТЕ Гроссі заявив, що всі
принципи ядерної безпеки було порушено.
Запорізька атомна електростанція - найбільша в Європі.
Російські війська захопили її ще на початку березня.
Гендиректор МАГАТЕ Рафаель Россі закликав
якнайшвидше дозволити експертам відвідати АЕС.
В Україні триває жорстока та кривава війна.
На захист Батьківщини стали
не лише професійні військові,
а й колишні інженери,
водії автобусів і тесляри.
Багато жінок, які раніше будували кар'єру,
теж беруться за зброю у цей кризовий момент.
Анна Брюль супроводжувала двох таких військових
біля Південної лінії фронту.
Вона має бойове ім'я «Відьма», так її, з поваги,
назвали чоловіки із підрозділу.
«Відьма» служить у складі спецзагону
української армії.
Нам дозволили бути присутніми на тренуванні,
яке відбувалося недалеко від лінії фронту.
Тренування - це моя щоденна рутина,
адже кожне бойове завдання потребує підготовки.
Як особистої, так і зброї.
Це моя відповідальність.
Снайпери, як і «Відьма», діють дуже близько
до лінії ворога.
Ми запитали, чи відчуває вона страх.
Так, я ж людина.
Військова не хоче показувати своє обличчя.
Чи вбивала вона на цій війні росіян і скільки,
«Відьма» відмовилася говорити.
Вона стріляє з відстані 900 м.
«Відьма» - одна з багатьох жінок,
задіяних у Збройних Силах України.
Загалом до ЗСУ долучилося 38 тис. жінок-військових.
Це одна з найвищих квот у світі.
Валентина Свинтовська також тут з власної волі.
Вона - юристка за фахом,
але тепер тримає зброю в руках.
Я нічим не відрізняюсь від чоловіків.
Я готова захищати свою країну.
На Південному фронті Україна
відвоювала деякі села.
На цій території служить і «Відьма».
Вона хоче продовжувати боротьбу,
як і багато жінок в Україні.
Більше інформації про українських жінок-військових
можна переглянути у «Auslandsjournal» о 22:15.
Понад 30 років тому стався
підпал будинку для шукачів притулку у Саарлуї.
Федеральна прокуратура висунула звинувачення
проти 50-річного чоловіка.
Підозрюється, що він вчинив підпал
через правоекстремістські погляди.
Чоловік із Республіки Гана
загинув внаслідок інциденту,
двоє інших були важко поранені.
Сьогодні поліція повідомляє,
що тогочасних розслідувань було недостатньо.
Їх занадто швидко припинили.
Лише два роки тому розслідування
відновили після появи нової інформації.
Світлофорна коаліція у Берліні домовилась
щодо нових коронавірусних заходів
на період осені та зими.
Локдауни не передбачаються, але з першого жовтня
масковий режим у громадських транспортах
та в медичних закладах буде обов'язковим.
Зокрема, обов'язкові й тести на коронавірус
у лікарнях та будинках для людей похилого віку.
Пізніше федеральні землі зможуть
запровадити суворіші правила.
Детальніше розповість Гайке Сланскі.
Зараз лише середина літа, але третя поспіль
осінь за час пандемії коронавірусу - не за горами.
Тижнями представлені у світлофорній коаліції
міністри охорони здоров'я та юстиції,
Лаутербах з партії SPD та Бушман з FDP відповідно,
борються за пакет заходів.
Сьогодні нарешті відбувся прорив.
Рішення - маски замість локдауну.
Усе, що стосується локдауну, а саме
комендантська година, закриття підприємств та шкіл,
ми більше не вважаємо доцільним.
Від жовтня до Великодня
у всій країні має діяти двоетапний план:
маска FFP2 у міжміських
та повітряних транспортних засобах,
у лікарнях та закладах з догляду та на підприємствах.
Крім того, федеральні землі
можуть запроваджувати подальші заходи.
Маска FFP2 у громадському транспорті,
закритих громадських місцях,
маска або тести в ресторанах
та в розважальних закладах.
Правила не діють для нещодавно одужалих
або вакцинованих.
Із нового: коротший інтервал між вакцинаціями.
За нашим визначенням - три місяці.
Тобто третє або інше щеплення має бути зроблене
не більш ніж три місяці тому.
Для шкільних класів, починаючи з п'ятого,
школярі також мають носити маски та робити тести.
Баварія на цю думку пристати не готова.
Немає конкретних вказівок щодо того,
що і коли запроваджувати.
Добрі наміри не завжди діють на благо.
Потрібно з'ясувати ще багато аспектів пандемічних заходів,
перш ніж застосовувати їх на практиці.
Я хотів би, аби це було простіше також і для громадян.
Землі в майбутньому мають самі ухвалювати рішення
з огляду на актуальність ситуації.
Концепція: більше особистої відповідальності
та можливостей для посилення безпекових заходів.
Зараз літо і на Німеччину насувається
четверта хвиля спеки.
Крім того, що спекотно, ще й занадто сухо.
Ось, наприклад, поточний стан ґрунту
аж ﻿до глибини 1,8 м.
Жовтий означає «надто сухий»,
і щотемніший червоний, то дедалі
сильніша фаза посухи.
Це має наслідки навіть для нашого використання води.
Франциска фон Тізенгаузен наведе приклади,
актуальні для багатьох регіонів Німеччини.
Потсдам влітку - рівень води все нижчий.
Тому з озер та річок більше не можна брати воду.
Хто знехтує забороною, ризикує отримати штраф
обсягом 50 тис. євро.
Для водопровідної води поки що обмежень немає.
Це полегшення для багатьох садівників,
адже дощів майже не було.
Я намагаюсь приходити сюди щоранку або щовечора
та поливати.
Інакше урожаю не буде.
Це важко і поливати потрібно багато.
У Шміттені в Таунусі ситуація ще складніша.
Громада оголосила надзвичайну ситуацію
з питною водою.
Це означає: для того, щоб полити квіти,
помити автомобіль тощо,
більше не можна використовувати воду з-під крана.
Вночі водопостачання на деякий час повністю перекривають.
Ми це розуміємо,
люди самі побачили, що потрібно економити.
Ні! Чому ні?
Тому що я вважаю, що це несправедливо
до людей, які мають поливати город.
Увесь урожай пов'яне.
Німеччина зазнає збитків від надзвичайної посухи
Та не схоже, що погодні умови скоро зміняться.
Ми відчуваємо кліматичну кризу.
Роками було надто сухо.
Уже попередні роки були надзвичайно посушливими.
2022 рік, здається, не відрізнятиметься.
У місті Герцберг-ам-Гарц люди також відчувають
наслідки спекотного та сухого літа.
На озері Юс швидко розмножилися
токсичні синьо-зелені водорості.
Купальний сезон завершено.
А зараз до новин спорту.
Приємне очікування Бундесліги зростає.
Вона розпочнеться вже цієї п'ятниці.
Володар Кубка «РБ Лейпциг» -
один із фаворитів у новому сезоні.
Звісно, ​​поряд із чемпіонами «Баварією Мюнхен»,
а також «Боруссією Дортмунд» та «Баєр 04 Леверкузен».
Жителі Лейпцига планують якомога довше
утримувати захоплення від боротьби за титул.
Вони хочуть бути на рівні з «Баварією».
Для цього Лейпцигу, перш за все,
потрібна швидкість.
Зокрема, клуб хоче повернути гравця Тімо Вернера.
«Челсі» просить за нього 33 млн євро,
Лейпциг поки у роздумах.
З новим гравцем національної збірної Давідом Раумом
Лейпциг також має того,
хто уособлює наступальний запал.
Я хочу допомогти команді.
Зміцнити її, а далі побачимо,
наскільки ми зможемо розізлити «Баварію».
Лейпциг також покладається на постійність.
Адже Конрад Лаймер досі грає за команду,
Найкращий бомбардир
Крістофер Нкунку подовжив свій контракт.
Залишається й травмований Йошко Гвардіол.
Адже Лейпциг відхилив запропонований
«Манчестер Сіті» трансфер обсягом 80 млн євро.
Йошко Гвардіол надзвичайно важливий для нас.
Після поразки 3:5 в Суперкубку проти
«Баварії» стало очевидно,
наскільки він потрібен Лейпцигу.
Після перемоги в Кубку та кваліфікації Ліги чемпіонів
«РБ Лейпциг» знову прагне
переможної ейфорії в цьому сезоні.
11 серпня в Мюнхені розпочинається
Чемпіонат Європи,
його можна переглянути в прямому ефірі
«ARD» та «ZDF».
Дизайн медалей, якими нагороджували
у дев'яти видах спорту,
нагадує літні Олімпійські ігри 1972 року
на тому ж місці,
з різними відтінками унікальної конструкції
шатрового даху в Олімпійському парку.
Як колись Усейн Болт, так сьогодні
Леціле Тебого з Ботсвани.
19-річний юнак перемагає у забігу на 100 м
із часом 9,91 с на Чемпіонаті світу
для вікової категорії до 20 років у Калі, Колумбія, -
це юніорський світовий рекорд.
Це швидше, ніж Болт у цьому ж віці.
Жести переможця майже ідентичні
жестам колишньої зірки спринту,
він негайно поділився своїм успіхом
у соціальних мережах.
Ось так буває. Дякую, Крістін.
А зараз переглянемо виграшні номери лотереї:
5, 11, 13, 21, 40, 43
Суперчисло: 9.
Більше виграшних номерів ви знайдете на lotto.zdf.de
і в «ZDFtext» на сторінці 557.
Подумайте над тим, що б хотіли завтра одягнути.
Буде дуже спекотно, більше про погоду
розповість Озден Терлі.
А о 21:45 на вас чекає випуск «heute journal»
з Крістіаном Зіверсом.
Дякую за ваш інтерес,
гарного вечора та до завтра.
Доброго вечора та вітаю у прогнозі погоди.
Тепло знову приходить до нас із південного заходу:
з Іспанії через Францію до Німеччини.
Цього літа так було вже декілька разів.
Пік спеки припаде на завтра.
Така погода прийде до нас із південного заходу,
але буде відсунута холодним фронтом,
який прибуде вже завтра ввечері.
У найближчу ніч майже нічого не відбудеться.
У небі видно зірки, температура
становитиме близько 20°С.
У великих містах показники термометра не нижчі.
Це величезне теплове навантаження.
Завтра буде дуже сонячно,
вдень із північного заходу насунуться зливи та грози,
вони можуть бути дуже сильними.
Найвищі температури, 39°С, очікуються
на північному заході Німеччини,
можливі навіть 40°С.
На сході країни - 37°С.
Завтра ввечері зливи та грози
перемістяться далі вглиб країни.
Cильний дощ, шквали та град.
У п'ятницю продовжаться сильні грози
у південно-східному напрямку,
температура становитиме до 35°С.